I am so grateful that I met this man
because I had gotten to a place where I
was pretty good being by myself but as
busy as I am running my Cynthia Bailey
Empire yes all right go to bed at night
alone and it is lonely and it feels
really good Real Housewives of Atlanta
Star Cynthia Bailey and her husband Mike
Hill call it quits after two years of
marriage I really want to you know run
toward my future with him because I'm
happy you know I love him and my peace
the two confirmed the news on Wednesday
telling E.T in a joint statement that
while they will always have love for one
another they have decided to go their
separate ways no one is to blame and we
are grateful that we remain good friends
we will always cherish the many memories
we've shared together as husband and
wife they also thanked fans for their
positive support as they move forward
and start new chapters we found on one
another and it's just I'm just happy to
be with her I mean because it is a
blessing it's the one of the best things
that's ever happened to me the reality
star and the Fox sports Personality sat
down with E.T back in 2018 and opened up
about their Whirlwind romance which
kicked off after the two met on Steve
Harvey's daytime talk show I was doing a
radio show at Fox and my co-host knew
one of The Producers over there and
asked me if I would go on to be one of
the Bachelors for a dating game and I
was like and they said one of Real
Housewives I said which one
and they said Cynthia Bailey I'm like oh
okay
Steve was like I'm not buying somebody
I'm gonna find somebody I was like yeah
yeah honey I have been out here
I've been on dating apps and everything
and I haven't found anybody how in the
world are you gonna find somebody but
the love connection almost didn't happen
Cynthia explained that Steve wanted her
to pick Mike so she went into the
segment telling herself she wouldn't
give Steve the satisfaction of choosing
his pick but all that changed when she
met Mike
what we got to do is we gotta just put a
couple of things together I picked you
because you were you were the one Mike
Hill is the one like I cannot believe
the words that come out of my mouth
he is the one he is the one I love this
man both Cynthia and Mike were married
before her divorce from ex-husband Peter
Thomas in 2017 was well documented on
Real Housewives well maybe I'm just not
in love with him anymore well you know
what
I just want to know when did you stop
loving me
I know neither one of us are perfect but
we're definitely perfect for one another
I just knew that if I'm gonna be in her
life and we're in love and that's part
of her but it's not see the thing is
it's not a storyline it's a love story I
really care for and so we have a good
time on the show the two got engaged
after a year of dating and tied the knot
in 2020. if it's in God's will for me to
be married again for us to be married
then this is the woman that I want to
marry I never thought I'd say that again
because I've been there before I do know
that uh if if it's somebody I want to be
with for the rest of my life it's going
to be Cindy Bailey
[Music]
thank you